doctor aspirin please the performance  enhancers aren't ready the data just  doesn't justify this test I'm asking for  the last time we can't do this don't be  a coward risks but part of laboratory  science but let me reschedule with a  proper medical staff in a volunteer I  mean if you just give me two weeks two  weeks two weeks we'll have lost the  contractor quest and the Oscorp will be  dead sometimes you got to do things  yourself  get me the Pro McClure apero seen for  what it begins catalyzation when the  vapor hits the bloodstream 40,000 years  of evolution and we barely even tapped  the vastness of human potential  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you  you